hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar mission possible
automating NGS sample prep for
challenging samples and niche
applications and duty over a
collaboration I'll be moderating the
session today's educational web seminars
presented by lab roots so leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual events and webinars
and dancing scientific collaboration and
learning it brought to you by Beckman
Coulter life sciences this webinar is
the third and final presentation in a
three-part series on laboratory
automation solutions for smaller NGS
labs those that are less familiar with
automation who are interested in
standardizing workflows and saving costs
through improved efficiency and results
this year Bettman culture life science
is celebrating 30 years in automation as
they continue to provide liquid handling
solutions to help accelerate reliable
results that drive scientific discovery
Beckman offers a full range of flexible
and scalable automated workstations and
integrated systems to automate genomic
cellular protein and other workflows in
a wide variety of research areas
including agriculture cancer and
infectious diseases cardiovascular
forensics and neurodegenerative
disorders for genomic applications
biomech automated workstations are
complemented by a growing portfolio of
nucleic acid extraction and purification
kits built on the company's patented
solid-phase reversible immobilization
SPR I magnetic feed technology let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind did you so simply type them
into the Q&A box which will open when
you click the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the precinct
just click on the support button found
at the top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the green Q&A button at
lower left I now presented a speaker's
David Horvath MS and Zack Smith ms or
both senior applications scientists for
beckman coulter life sciences david
automates propriety and third-party next
generation sequencing chemistry's he has
a masters of science and medical and
molecular genetics from the Indiana
University School of Medicine David's
career experiences span a broad range of
life science fields including forensic
DNA analysis medical diagnostics and
agricultural biotech sac automates
propriety and third-party next
generation sequencing kit he has a
master's in environmental science in
Indiana University previously that was
at the university center for genomics
and bioinformatics as a project
scientist David will now begin his
presentation good morning everybody and
thank you for attending this third part
in our small apps webinar series today
you mention we're going to be talking
about automating NGS sample prep for
challenging sample types and nisha
applications just a quick recap of the
first part of the webinar series we
reviewed our our workflow for automating
NGS applications of workflows so this is
our application development process this
webinar and the second webinar are
available for replay online and you can
review the siskel and jet workflow but
our general processes or scoping out
developing the applications for market
research to generating our data
application notes posters etc and
including the application installation
and post installation support and we
also talked a little bit about some of
our new software features including our
biomech method launcher and Kyle ever
set up features as well as dark or data
access
reporting tool which can be included as
an enhancement here you're biomech
software the second part of our webinar
series reviewed several DNA and RNA seek
applications in the list here again you
can replay that webinar online as well
so today's presentation will discuss
essentially for nesha applications will
be talking about ffpe derived RNA
samples using automated to seek RNA
access library truck cell-free DNA whole
genome sequencing using the rubicon
genomics through flex plasma seek it
targeted amplicon stephenson using
illumina's true seat custom hammock on
low input library prep kit and then also
HLA typing applications using aluminous
truesight HLA sequencing reference panel
so the start we'll discuss ffpe RNA seek
so aren't I taking the RNA sequencing
with ffpe derived samples can be
challenging so fixed formal and
paraffin-embedded human tissue samples
are common in cancer research and
already derived from this tissue type
suffers from a number of problems for
ngf sample preparation these can include
degradation of the poly a tail and mrna
species which makes a logo BTW captured
difficult as well as degradation of
ribosomal RNA species that may result in
imperfect ribosomal RNA removal occurred
using standard ribosomal depletion
strategies the chemistry that we
automated was the Illumina to see
guarding access library prep kit and see
workflow for this kid aims at overcoming
the challenges of FFP
just described by doing an excellent
Richman versus the traditional poly a
capture or ribosomal depletion so the
exit own enrichment is going to focus on
the coding region of the RNA because of
that it requires less sample input from
fresh and frozen tissue input
requirements are only ten nanograms and
for ffpe material inputs are 20
nanograms because we're just focusing on
the exome sequencing requires fewer
reads which can allow you to increase
the amount of samples per sequencing run
and also provide the more cost-effective
transcriptome analysis so to the right
here is a graphic of the RNA access
workflow it's not intended on showing
the detail necessarily but just to show
you the lengths of the protocol the
complexity of it and the next slide kind
of gives Sun condensed you of that
workflow so essentially there's the cdna
synthesis module we have the traditional
a tailing allegation steps prior to
hybridization we include a
quantification normalization and cooling
module and then we carry into the exome
capture the hybridization steps followed
by a final capture amplification
enrichment and clean up so the challenge
points again with this with ffpe
material and with the RNA access kit you
to its length of time for processing and
complexity of the the preparation that
we're dealing with highly complex and
time-consuming protocols with nine
reaction mix additions 6am pure XP
cleanups and to hybridization captures
our automation solution eliminates the
highly repetitive and time-consuming
tasks with only one and a quarter hours
of hands-on
for the entire three-day method low
input sample requirements are
challenging for this particular
application and the method supports
either ten anagrams of total RNA or
twenty nanograms of ffpe derived RNA
with high recovery with our anterior XP
clean up or even clean up steps so
traditionally with Beckman applications
we provide a intuitive user interface to
drive all the method options for
applications so this application allows
you to process any number of samples
between 1 and 96 and includes five
distinct modules with built-in start and
stop points which correspond to the
alumina recommended stage stopping
points we provide flexible index labra
options and index transfer options in
next lab where could include using the
kits directly sorry the two directly
from the kit your own customer rating
plate and then is the option of doing
automatic adapter transfers or custom
transfer by file we included
quantitation set up module for pika
green quantitation following the first
pcr amplification that will provide the
steps needed to set up your pee go green
reagent and then once you get the
results from your pika green
quantitation it will set up the
normalization and pool mapping for you
before going into hybridization
optionally we have T robot integration
which is the on-deck thermal cycler and
that will increase the walkaway
capability of the method in providing
more time for technicians robotic users
to be performing more valuating work
versus tending to the automation to move
sample plates on and off thermal cyclers
throughout the day
along with our methods we include a
reagent calculator so the region
calculator will automatically provide
master mix recipe preparation
instructions to the user based on the
number of samples and particular modules
that were selected to run for that part
of the application it will detail the
lab where configuration the sample and
reagent tube or reservoir fill volumes
and it updates automatically based on
the sample number and Method options
selected by the user so here we'll
describe some of the the QC data coming
from the RNA axis kit so the images
you're seeing here are bioanalyzer
tracings following the first pcr
enrichment prior to hybridization so the
upper left graph are overlaid uhr RNA
control libraries following the first
pcr enrichment in the lower left we have
brain RNA control libraries following
the first pcr enrichment and the other
right we have ffpe RNA controls
following first DCR enrichment so as you
can see we have consistent sizing and
ultimately consistent yields from the
replicas of each of those control types
in the lower right we have these
bioanalyzer tracings following
hybridization so this is going to be
your sample a common completion of the
entire our taxes method just before
getting ready to sequence so we have 4
flex pool libraries and there's two
replicates for each of the control
groups here following the second pcr
enrichment so again consistent sizing
and consistent sample yields from each
of the control types sequencing metrics
are as follows we have very high
percentage of line breeds then greater
than ninety percent of the captured
targets were aligned to the expected
coding region of the genome on the
contaminant breeze
on the upper right the scale is 3.5
percent of the top so what we're seeing
here is the amount of contaminant or non
non target breathe so we're looking at a
very small percentage of ribosomal RNA
remaining in our final-final library and
reducing the amount of ribosomal
component that's getting mapped and
therefore increasing the amount of the
winery's to the coding region conference
uniformity and stranded asst we have
very good very high inconsistent
coverage uniformity across all sample
replicates and control types and also a
high degree of strength specific
specificity excuse me okay and the
alignment distribution we have a high
percent aligning to the coding region so
greater than seventy percent a small
percent alliance with the untranslated
region intronic regions or intergenic
regions we have less than three percent
abundance and less than two percent
ribosomal RNA component with an average
of greater than 12 million pass filter
reads on a high c grown the data is
highly reproducible across sample types
including lower quality ffpe material
the kit provides low percent duplicates
for the uhr and the brain control
samples less than twenty percent and
relatively low PCR duplicates
considering the grid in nature of the
fft material highly reproducible median
insert size is also seen across the
replicates of all the controls so in
summary the true Sikh RNA access
automated method generates 96 highly
enriched XM libraries in less than three
days with only 1.5 hours of hands-on
time it includes feature-rich user
interfaces and reagent calculators to
create flexible workflows
and reduce setup errors and provide
high-quality robots RNA seek data with
greater than 12 million pass filter
reads minimal percent abundance and
percent ribosomal component with highly
reproducible results the second
challenging sample type or niche
applications I want to discuss today
relates to cell free DNA so what is cell
free DNA it's also referred to as CF DNA
it's highly fragmented DNA in the blood
that is shed from tumor cells or can be
shed from tumor cells and there's a high
abundance of CF DNA from tumor cells in
cancer patients so why is this important
so plasma along with other liquid
collapse these are easily available
sample types and given that these sample
types contains the FDA they can be used
to interrogate mutation cancer mutations
or any translational research in
oncology in addition research involving
the field fraction maternal plasma can
be conducted using prenatal testing
non-invasive prenatal testing and be
able to interrogate the CF DNA in that
sample material so we've automated a CF
DNA application using the through Plex
plasma seek chemistry from rubicon
genomics rubicon chemistry generates NGS
libraries from cell free DNA isolated
from plasma it's optimized for low input
CF DNA samples less than 1 anagram to 13
anagrams of input it's fast and simple
library prep process performed in a
single two three step process it
provides extremely low PCR duplicates
providing maximum library complexity and
it preserves the GC representation of
the input
DNA cell free DNA sequencing has several
challenge points with this particular
chemistry there's repetitive pipetting
of enzymes indices and challenges during
sample cleanup are prone to errors and
fatigue so our application provides full
automation solutions eliminating the
highly repetitive and time-consuming
tasks and when combined with an
integrated service legler becomes a
complete walk away solution the low
input nature of CF DNA library prep
requires assurance of maximum sample
recovery so we have highly optimized by
petting to deliver highly accurate and
reproducible transfers of small reaction
volumes ensuring the most robust
reaction chemistry we've automated the
rubicon genomics through Plex plasma
seek it on the biomech FX while we use
the FX for this particular application
it is definitely scalable to an EDX
whether it be an enhanced multi-select
tip multi-channel head or a spanning pod
as well as being transferable down to
our entry level instrument of biomech
4000 so as you can see on the left that
the Rubicon workflow is relatively
simple the workflow on the left is
essentially as a 3-step and dramatic and
dramatic reaction that's added it to a
single place at the end of that the
three and medic reactions there's a safe
stop point and then the method can be
continued from that point with the final
pcr cleanup we provide a user interface
which is the user options to choose
various parts of the methods to run so
there's flexible work watch us either
for
the reaction chemistry or the cleanup
together or separate it includes lab or
transfer options it includes trusted and
pure XD cleanup and also has options for
T robot integration the rubicon genomics
reflex plasma see kids also was
developed with our new guy lever set up
feature so if you're familiar with the
existing instrument setup it provides an
image of the deck upon execution of the
run but it's a little bit limited in
being able to resolve stacks glad we're
or to provide additional detail about
lab we're set up so I've got a lever set
up is able to break down placement of
ladder on the deck lab where my lab
where and provide any step-by-step
instructions to the user including how
much sample to fill where it place it
how many wells should be filled based on
the number of samples you flexing the
user interface etc in addition stack lab
where is now able to be resolved through
a profile view so any stack lab or under
deck is displayed on the far right in a
profile view so you can see each level
each stack of lab where in hand the
order that it needs to be placed on the
deck when you drill down into a
particular piece of lab where guy lever
set up has the capability to present the
any information specific to filling
wells within that lab or so in this
example we're looking at the reagent
block and there's recipe master mix
preparation instructions they're
highlighted in the red and green boxes
and those recipes are specific to the
number of samples of the user selected
in the user interface and then it
provides instruction on the reagent
block itself as to which wells are to be
specifically filled with those mixtures
also we have our new biomech method
launcher feature that's compatible with
the three flex plasma seat kit and what
this does is
by a real time milestone or update view
of where you're at in your run and
provides information regarding about the
parameters you selected in your user
interface a real-time view of biomech
lab where on the instrument decks and
also allows you to have resolution of
any lab or data sets during the run that
could include barcodes volume sample IDs
index numbers etc you can interrogate
those values in the course of your honor
lastly the biomech magic launcher also
provides a web-enabled live run
monitoring capability via a smartphone
tablet or desktop PC so we'll talk a
little bit about the data from the
rubicon through flex plasma seek it so
what you're seeing on the left our viral
analyzer tracings across a wide range of
inputs from 0.1 nanograms to 5 nanograms
you can see that there's consistent
yield and consistent sizing from each of
those sample inputs that's due to the
method being able to modify the cycle
parameters depending on your sample
input so that the final libraries come
out with consistent yield on the right
we're showing average concentrations of
plasma seed libraries for 15 and 10
nanograms input as well as an NTC sample
so you can see there's highly
reproducible results for each of those
sample inputs and then across inputs the
yields are consistent as well sequencing
data for the true plex plasma feed
chemistry shows highly complex library
with greater than 50 million reads for
library is well as low percent PCR
duplication for one anagram 5-man agree
and 10 milligrams being below five
percent pcr duplication 0.1 nanograms as
higher pcr duplication than the one or
higher nanogram inputs although it's
still extremely low less than twenty
percent for an input of only 0.1
anagrams so in summary the automated
version of the rubicon genomics through
plex plasma see chemistry on the biomech
effects provides 96 libraries generated
in approximately three and a half hours
from low input CFDA it reduces errors
from repetitive pipetting provides true
aqua weight capability with T robot the
recycling integration and provides
highly reproducible results with low pcr
duplicates with input amounts as low as
0.1 nanograms it now pass it off to my
colleague Zack Smith to will describe
additional niche and challenging sample
applications I think it is and thank you
all for hanging with us second half of
the presentation I'm going to talk about
two applications one is around the
applicant sequencing and the other one
is about HLA typing which could be
considered a very example con sequencing
so really what is amplicon sequencing
well amplicon sequencing this way of
being targeted DNA sequencing it uses
pcr-amplified discrete regions of a
genome for high coverage sequencing
usually for variant screening and so for
example you want to be able to zero in
and find specific groups of snips and a
limited number of genes so you would use
this for looking at tumor
characterization for example and other
projects such as the Falcon genomes
project is using this to characterize
snips and other variants found in
various ethnic groups around the world
so it has a number of applications just
for people for agriculture it's their
output becoming a good way of a type it
crops out and for cattle and such so it
so it's expanding into a wide variety of
applications so the kid we wanted to
discuss as a way of providing an
amplicon solution stay with the alumina
torrisi custom and work on low input
library prep kit it's the kid is is a
quite rapid that's not very long
workflow at all it allows you to
generate up to 1536 amplicons for each
sample the panel's themselves can be
created using a limited design studio
software so you would design your panel
and limited would send you a panel
abhava goes and then you would take that
in conjunction with the kit and then you
would do to do your library preparation
so just some of the potential challenge
points that we see with this one so
accommodating wide number of sample
inputs or method user interface adjust
for applying to run from anywhere up to
12 96 samples and just the adjustment
protocol automatically in terms of
master mixes and lab where for example
and the other thing is the ability to
incorporate in lab controls so the
alumina kit provides with a couple of
imply controls a positive control using
2810 DNA that's provided in the kit and
negative rs1 control we have the option
in the method to use those or not we
would strongly recommend you didn't it's
a look at our recommends using them but
we realize that some facilities might
not be necessarily interested in working
with humans so we gave the option of
putting that that option in the method
so our amazing solution for the true see
custom and become low input method was
developed for the biomech FX PS you can
see here on the slide it effectively is
two modules you do your amplicon library
generation and then you do your post
post and rhythmic pcr cleanup
normalization and pooling the method
itself we do have a template version for
the NX p span 8 but the data i'm going
to show you
generated up on the fxp here regardless
of which platform we are doing we're
going to be using this on the user
interface would remain the same so these
are your faces show here it's basically
just a couple of options to allow you to
Braun to include in line controls you
run the double-stranded protocol method
or just running single-stranded and you
would enter in your number of samples
and whether or not you're going to use
an on deck thermocycler or not and then
depending on the options you select in
the user interface you get a few other
options on how to deploy indices and
whether you want the instrument to
automatically assign indices to the
libraries or if you would like to do
that with a pile driven tram the index
transfer and then how much volumes you
want approval for sequencing select the
rubicon method now this meant that also
takes advantage of our new biomech
method monitor software specifically
they got a lab or set up so as you can
see here we'll be able to go through the
go through the deck and be able to see
what is the you know what you know where
you put in which lab where what in the
case of Master mixes how to create each
how much of each composed will need to
create a master make somewhere to
located on the on the deck so we've got
an example of the of the 24 position
blue tube rack here and where you would
put all the various master mixes on
there and what lines you would need
depending on the number of samples
you've selected so just real quickly I
wanted to go through some of the data we
generated so we ran to automation runs
with 86 10 milligram promega human
reference DNA technical replicates and
ten water- controls for run and we use
the true see cancer amplicon panel for
our amplicon
to the kit the take station trace you're
seeing sort of the center of the slide
there it's just an overlay of our
various technical replicates and then
the pocket controller double on the top
for the UN cosmic control and then the
rs1 negative controls on the top you can
see we've got a signal on our positive
control and the signal in our data
controller it's just quite happy we then
ran the samples through each sequencing
realm is done on a single my secret and
generators approximately 25 million
raised for each run the graphs on the
top of this slide show they read
alignment for each each run so we've got
quite high read alignment for each of
the samples as you can see it's greater
than ninety percent for the vast
majority of our of our technical
replicates and then the two graphs that
are below show the panel coverage by
library so we do have some variation
panel coverage but it's not it's
approximately to the other the average
coverage for each library group is
approximately 2500 X coverage for the
entire panel so the percent uniformity
of the coverage was approximately 96 or
point 96 this this data was generated
using the alumina true Sikh amplicon app
on the basin on the base base so we then
also took the base base data and I
wanted to see how we were looking at as
far as consistency on coverage on
individual reasons of interest so
breaking it down into the individual 226
regions that are covered by the ack-ack
cancer amplicon panel I averaged out all
the coverage for each of the 86
technical replicates as you can see
between runs we had quite quite good
reproducibility as far as in terms of
coverage across regions of interest so
our run to run compare
were quite good for the true Sikh custom
amplicon moment okay okay so for hla
typing mitchell early typing could be
considered a variant of apricot
sequencing so but why are we interested
in it so the HOA systems is the human
leukocyte antigen system it plays a role
a significant role in the body's ability
to recognize and detect forward and
infectious agents as well as malfunction
cells and consists of 21 genes and their
various alleles there has been about
reside on chromosome 6 there's been over
over 12,000 wheels discovered as of
January 2015 and research for hla typing
includes a number of applications
including for bone marrow and solid
organ transplants there are a number of
autoimmune disorders that are links to
variations in HLA alleles and so and as
well certain cancer so it's a drag it's
a very active field of research so the
vast majority of lasses are still doing
actually typing they're still doing it
with higher sequencing and that it you
usually have multiple assays or tests
for sample more than 30 and asked these
are tedious and the ultras old and
ambiguous HLA typing calls and false
positives are even more worrisome so the
question was how could we apply how
could a company of lions yes technology
to hla typing and so luminant has
recently released a new version of the
true side hla hla be too which is quite
an improvement over that would be one
kid in terms of the complexity of the
workflow but as you can see it's still a
fairly complex workflow the workflow is
here on the right side of your screen in
terms of just what the the bench
operations that you would require to do
the kid self covers 11 HLA low side
covers three Class A or Fox 11 including
HLA a B and C and covers eight of the
class too low so as you can see here on
the screen
drv 1345 eq a 12 B 1 and B 1 and it
covers all of those in a single a safe
effective leaper per sample so the
genomic an example you will amplify out
the eight amplicon pools effectively /
genomic DNA sample and then those will
be those will be after the initial PD
long-range pcr and create the amplicons
will perform a clean up on those the
next step is you will do normalization
and tagged Minh tation of the amplicons
and then after temptation their pool
back on a per sample basis and then you
there's an indexing pcr step and then a
couple of cleanups and reports ready to
go on to the sequencer so quite an
improvement over the v1 chemistry some
challenge points for this kit the
workflow is fairly complex it requires a
substantial amount of manual pipetting
as you saw from the previous diagram our
automation solution uses the modular
workflow design and reduces the user
interaction allows for easy deployment
in multiple laboratory configurations so
because the method itself is modular we
can take it and we can split it into
whatever configuration is required for
the lab if they have a pre room in a
post room we can break it up that way
quite quickly processing multiple
samples we can profits anywhere from one
to twenty four samples within two days
within a time frame provided by aluminum
that's how many examples the kit will
will support and but we're using by a
magnetic launcher or software with God
lab we're set up to provide intuitive
set of instructions for reagents in lab
where because we realize that setup
errors doing this in the real world so
so here's a just a quick map of the
automation solution so we developed this
method on the biomech and XP span a
system that configuration you see there
and effectively we have four modules the
hla implication set up that list is in
green primarily so you can split it off
into your pre room and then we have a
julienne become clean up normalization
and segmentation and
segmentation or modules so the black
arrows indicate places where you will
have to interact with the instrument in
order to put additional lab or on the
tech tips plays etc and you're running
more than 12 samples the red arrows have
indicated an additional interaction you
would have to do if you were to scale
this method on the FX obviously there
would be fewer interactions that you
would need to scale it down to the
bottleneck 4000 potentially more
interactions than this so without the ax
Pete would be a good cost-effective
solution for a sub 100k the solution for
hla typing again this method is as
compatible by Mac method launcher so you
would just add it to your launcher and
you would have your technician launch
the method to launcher rather than
launching it to the biomech software if
you want to go down that road these are
interface is extremely simple there's a
drop down menu that allows you to select
which module you want to run and you
enter the number of samples for 12 24
and then depending on which module
you're running you will get some
additional options will pop up in the
user interface and again we're utilizing
lab we're set up on this method one
things we could do with that lever set
up as we can very accurately display
what needs to be put we're on to that so
as you can see on the image on the right
hand side screen that's all the HLA
amplification primers and we have
color-coded well based on the caps the
correspond with the aluminum protocol so
that then we can go through and the user
can simply take those tubes from me for
the education setup war for me i five by
seven industry indexing take caps off
put them in the well that you go in and
put them straight on the back so here's
some data from a run we did we performed
a fixed sample run with I hwg DNA
provided by alumina for six different
cell lines the bile analyzer traces
you're seeing on the left would be false
gel image are the amplicons after
they've been
ample food after the long-range
amplification has been performed and
they've been cleaned up excuse me and
then the bioanalyzer trace from the top
is the is the finished library pools
after they have been completely
processed and ready to go on the
sequencer so we performed a single
sequencing run using a mighty p 2 300
cycle micro kit and generated 4.2
million pass filter reads which we were
able to identify 96.7 percent of them
based on barcodes you can see below
we've got the percent reads identified
graph great calm to bring each of the
six Santa monarchy to the safe library
pools we were sequencing and then some
mean quality scores will run so
generative large number of equities and
then we've had the fast queue data off
to aluminum is there a truce i th 0 8 9
software 2 point 0 to do the HLA calls
and so this is a software is provided by
aluminum when you when you purchase then
you can purchase the software through
aluminum for actually doing the HLA
typing calls we identified only too
ambiguous DTV ones and alleles in one
sample out of 108 oils that were
sequence total and we compared a list of
98 alleles associated with our six
samples our results were 97% concordant
with the I hwg calls there are three
discordant remote haul results that we
believe can be contributed to incorrect
HLA reference types of the IV reference
type that was assigned the cell line by
the HW g group was not correct and this
is something that we see quite
frequently when we're dealing with hla
data from in gs is that we can because
we are sequencing at such a higher depth
than what you can get for Sanger that
there are more and more and more very
encouraging discovered and believe
alumina has just released a white paper
on this on the subject so um that
largely concludes our presentation for
today if you have
interest in our NGS applications we have
the flag on our web page info pakman.com
slash NGS for more information where you
can see all of our validated and
demonstrated methods and what platforms
we've developed the morning and thank
you very much for your time and your
attention and with that we'll take some
questions thank you David and Zach for
your presentation so a quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them in the Q&A
box down by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window David and Zach will
answer as many questions time permits
the first question is what is involved
in moving a next-generation sequencing
method between platforms for example
moving between a biomech fxp and a
biomed 4000 okay I could answer that
question so obviously there's there's
major differences between an fx and a
biomech 4000 FX has two pods so we
accomplish parts of the protocol in
different ways using the two pods so the
multi-channel probably used for vault
cleanups typically our space pod is used
for enzymatic delivery so when we scaled
down to an NX were moving away from the
dual pods listened to a single pod
system so both of our pots are capable
of processing the chemistry although the
major by way of which that the transfers
are handled are just inherently
different using the multi-channel and a
span a pod same with the bottleneck 4000
it uses a series of tools a little bit
different than what you see with the
span a pod so to convert down to the
smaller platforms the method structure
and the workflow generally stays the
same and it's just a matter of reworking
the steps to to fit the hardware
essentially are there other NGS based
HLA typing a phase and are you able to
automate them yeah I can take that one
yes there are other energy essbase
actually typing assays
including the the Hemi core / sarona
chemistry that I believe has already
been automated on the biomech 4000 by
sironi there's also a GS go and mix on
as well we are we were able to automate
any and every one of them on our
platforms are biomech liquid handlers
our chemistry agnostic so we don't
really mind who's who's chemistry we're
whose chemistry we're automating so so
yes we can take this what kinds of
panels is alumina to see Christ amplicon
support yeah I can take that one as well
so the to see custom amplicon panels are
generating all the designs using the
luminous design studio software for the
low-income or for the lowest balloon
cook kit they generally recommend
restricting it to 1536 amplicons per
sample for those panels I know that the
two-seat custom amplicon one burning 1.5
can support several you know basically
tens of thousands depending on what you
want to do with it so a larger depends
on what what coverage you need and what
what model system you're working with
how does biomech software handle
regulatory compliance and also is there
a way of capturing electronic signatures
yeah I can I can take that yeah so with
bionics offer we have defined that
accounts of permissions that are be cap
software animal that you can put on by
mix that allows it to comply with CFR
part 21 compliance so basically you can
restrict access to certain methods based
on the user you can also require can
also require electronic signatures for
every time the methodist change so
basically allows you to track changes of
the method and lock them down
effectively so
and army I'm sorry go ahead oh no no
please finish I'm sorry I'm sorry finish
oh please go ahead yes you guys yeah I
think you go out to the I'm sorry yeah
sorry bout this okay ten RNA access
methods work with highly degraded FFPE
samples yes the our taxes kit has
recommended inputs for different DV 200
quality readings so the kick is designed
to work with samples DB 200 greater than
or equal to 30 so the 29er gram input
that I described was using FF relatively
high quality FFP materia with the DV 200
value of approximately seventy percent
and the kit gives recommended guidelines
of increasing the RNA input as the DB
200 value decreases to i believe up to a
14 anagram input for lower quality ffpe
he's the biomech effects a walk away
instrument merging the operators have to
babysit it I could get an accident or so
the of course that the walkway system
automation is going to allow the user to
start the run and then let the
automation should work for you the walk
away capability really depends on the
workflow for example some processes are
going to be broken up as a separate
module depending on how much lab orders
on the deck so if there's a capacity
issue and you can't include all the lab
where from the very beginning of
three-day process to the end and
obviously there's going to be break
points with the army access method
23 de workflow so there's break points
associated with the safe stopping points
from the limit of protocol so it's walk
away from safe stop points to say stop
one and sometimes across multiple safe
stop points including depending on the
length of each of those modules you know
the other thing to consider is you can
automate any Indian just workflow and
hitting one of our lipid handlers but
obviously the by my for thousands got a
much smaller deck and it may or may not
have an integrated thermocycler although
it can have integrated recycler and so
depending on the hardware configuration
at a particular site you may or may not
need to have more interactions with the
instrument just a load lab or I mean if
you've got an integrated thermocycler
and you got off you know op tech lab
where storage like an automated Labrador
nominated lab where feeder or side in
that unit then the instrument couldn't
you know you couldn't build it into a
completely walk away solution large just
depends on what the configuration is
going to look like and in the workflow
tends to vary from customer site the
customer site so we're able to configure
the walk away capability of these
applications to fit the the users
expected workflow or as a fitted
workflow some customers don't actually
want to run samples for an entire day
beginning to end they prefer to to run
in more of a modular fashion so we
create those breakpoints when
appropriate and work with each
customer's to develop a workflow that
fits their needs it's the poster
available to view or the entire
presentation yeah the entire webinar
will be available on demand with
elaborate pollen broadcast and I don't
know as the rubicon summaries why there
is a poster screenshot think that might
be what questions referring to oh I
don't know that that can be made
available and we'll be able to provide a
link you know where the webinar
that poster yeah we also have a variety
of application notes that we've
developed for all these these methods so
if you just go to our Beckman NGS
website you should be able to download
an application as for each of the
applications that we've disgusted it if
you want you know more in the more
detailed view of the method or you
actually want to dig into the data a
little bit further what is the
difference between validated and
demonstrated method so yes sir validated
method is we don't use the term
validated validated it's going to be a
term used by our more of a diagnostic
term customer will validate their method
in house to meet very specific
performance expectations of the customer
our qualification status from our
applications or either demonstrated or
qualified qualified is actually a term
that illumina uses it's not specific to
all vendors each better that we work
with may have a particular metric or
data suspect that they're looking to
achieve when we're developing our
applications with them and each vendor
will qualify or give a thumbs up on our
application when it meets meets those
specifications when we say a
demonstrated method what we've shown is
that in house we've demonstrated that it
provides robust performance we've
generated data and are able to to
generate data on the automated system
that's comparable to a manual prep in
addition to just generating bioanalyzer
data or quantification data we carry our
samples through the sequencing or the
appropriate sequencing platform to show
the robustness of the actual sequencing
data and generates even sigmetrics
around that as well so kind of close
that gap on the what your final results
are going to look like
evaluated value-adding your data will be
using our applications is there an
automated way to do quantification and
QC on the biomech yeah I can answer that
yes there is an automated way to do
qualifications and QC on the biotech we
have automated a number of different
ways of doing that so we we have
automated for example the setup of the
Agilent tape station on the biomech we'd
have automated the use of four metric a
say such as Pico breathe for play based
assays we've also automated the kappa
alumina PNA qualification kit for one
find the final libraries also on the FX
and that speaks to one of the things
that I like about our liquid handlers is
that it's not a purpose-built box and so
all the other ancillary methods that you
need to do nor to get a sample ready for
NGO sample prep included qualification
arraying out of various sample tubes if
your report facility or you're probably
getting lots of different tubes from
various Camino outfits and they may or
may not be labeled properly but that's
not something we can help you out with
but it performs all those operations and
so you're not getting effectively a
one-trick pony with our systems and
that's that's where you work with your
your field application scientists to to
really share your workflow with them
beyond justed library prep need so
there's there's work upstream of that
via extraction protocol that flow into
rearrange protocols which flow into
cloth protocols NGS prep the actual
sequencing preparation qpcr and then all
those particular processing needs can be
accomplished with one system with
multiple applications serving that
entire workflow process yeah this
different culture has chemistry for
nucleic acid extraction yes we do we
have a variety of chemistry that we sell
for nucleic acid extraction including
DNA advance or for isolating DNA from
tissue we have our RNA advanced
chemistry's for a variety of tissue
types including blood and tissue as well
we also have a kit called farm cure that
we use for extracting nucleic acids from
ffpe materials and so we have a variety
of chemistry's that are built around
hours fri technology that we can use for
isolated nucleic acids in as a part of
getting the sample ready for your NGS
sample prep so we're not just an
automation vendor we're also a reagent
editor as well what support is available
for applications that are challenging to
implement what support for invasion so
our demonstrated methods are typically
built in collaboration with the kit
fender in addition we we generally have
customer collaborators as well to get
the real world story you know what what
is they to look like from real world
samples so our SAS field application
scientists will take those demonstrated
methods that we developed with the
chemistry vendor with our collaborators
and then they work with the individual
customer sites to configure to their
specific needs and we'll triage with the
kiss benders and provide a holistic
approach to support so not just
implementing the method you know
transferring on a USB stick to your
computer but making sure that method is
up and running configured pipetting
optimized and then we stick with you
until you see that the data is up to
your specifications our all message
dealt with
okay okay sorry about that are all
methods built with your biomass method
launcher and as a customer how can I get
a copy and have existing methods
converted I can take that one so we we
didn't use my momentum launcher at sles
earlier this year and since then we've
made it a standard part of all of our
in-house developed methods the launcher
software is two components you have the
launcher which you interact with the
method with and then there's a guided
lab or set of functionality that shows
you the image of the deck and the stack
lab or and so on so on and such guided
lab or set up we can get that out to you
fairly quickly put launcher there is a
fee for that one but it's not you know
it's not very expensive at all if you
want to know more information about the
pricing structure just please give it
give us an email and we'll be happy to
get you in touch with a sales person can
a thermal cycler be integrated on up I
am at 4000 absolutely integrated nervous
I colors can be included on all of our
platforms so the back 4,000 mechanics
and biomech effects with direct direct
integration to the deck without
requiring external shuttles arms etc I
would like to once again thank David
Horvath and Zack Smith for their
presentation do you have any final
comments thank you all very much for
your time tickly those of you to the
soldier gone through three of these with
us it's been fun and hopefully we'll see
you soon I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and further
interesting questions we would also like
to thank our sponsor beckman coulter
life sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast the preceding two
webinars in this series are available on
demand on the labyrinth website part one
is easy automation solutions better
results in part two is DNA and RNA
sequencing sample prep automating simple
to complex methods this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit
the sub caste can be viewed on demand
through january twenty eight twenty
seventeen lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay i
only encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues whom you have
missed today's live events until next
time goodbye